We should address the latest developments in
the steps turns my lords where I wonder is our
Prince Daemon it was a decade ago and he has since
left the region undefended we have left undefended
my queen her father compromised
by the acts of her son
to have one child like that is mistake death three
is an insult what are children but a weakness
through them you imagine you will
persist forever you will be our King
people have eyes the consequences of
an allegation like the one you two had
we are the blood of old valyria but for
them you surrender what you should not
will be dire. Dracarys.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie they just
released a house of the Dragon episode 6 trailer
with a bunch of new footage so we'll break it down
there's obviously a huge time Jump I believe it's
about 10 years so a bunch of stuff has happened
since the events of episode 5 when we pick up
in episode six I'll explain what's going on if
you're brand new to the channel I'm doing videos
for all the episodes just like I did for the
Game of Thrones series be sure to subscribe to
get them we're also doing a giveaway for HBO Max
subscriptions to all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and post your favorite moment
from the new trailer on the video careful for
spoilers from episode 5 if you haven't seen it yet
because obviously we have to talk about where they
left things to talk about where they begin here so
like I said about 10 years have gone by a bunch of
children have been born to both of the different
sides like rhaenyra has a couple children now
alicent has a couple more children in addition to
the ones that she already had and probably one of
the other biggest changes is now that they've
switched to the older versions of the actresses
so now rhaenyra is being played by Emma d'arci
i she's wearing a similar gown that renira had
earlier in the timeline just to kind of ease the
transition like oh she looks like she's wearing
the same clothes she's kind of looks the same but
not really and alicent is being played by Olivia
Cooke now wearing green almost all the time even
though she does wear different types of gowns most
of them are all green for the most part for the
rest of her life when her children are fighting
with rhaenyra's children they also want to show
you that alicent's children also wear green like
she does and rhaenyra's children are wearing red
and black to denote the different sides in the
dance of the Dragons It's foreshadowing at this
point like it hasn't actually started but it's
eventually spinning up really soon we'll just
started the beginning of the trailer though and
go through scene by Scene It starts with a scene
of Daemon on caraxes flying to Dragonstone they
mention him in a small council meeting with the
older versions of the actresses like both alicent
and rhaenyra are there viserys is there as well
but obviously he's gotten way worse since the
events of episode 5. his hair's falling out he
looks like he's over 90 years old even though
he's still a middle-aged man like he's still
meant to be very young chronologically it's
just that his leprosy is slowly eating away at
him he has a form of leprosy and that's really
what's killing him so it looks like he has a lot
of trouble or just getting around normally like
you see him sitting down a lot the same people
are on the small Council like Thailand Lannister
who's speaking here in the small council meeting
talking about the situation in the stepstones is
still the master of ships so even though viserys
formed the marriage pact between their houses and
kind of made nice with House of Velaryon. Corlys
Velaryion hasn't come back to the small Council
the whole idea here is that Daemon basically
vacated the stepstone so now it's become a big
problem people from essos are trying to take it
again and even though the stepstones aren't part
of Westeros they don't want somebody from the East
controlling it because it's such a big point of
trade around the Seven Kingdoms that was the whole
reason why Corlys Velaryon wanted to fight that
war in the first place because they were choking
his trade you can see the tensions between alicent
and rhaenyra have cooled significantly it's been
10 years so obviously there's a lot of stuff
that they skipped over like things just gradually
got worse and worse and worse all the voice over
here in the trailer talking about children being
the end of people basically this big metaphor is
coming from Larys Strong Lord of Tea because he's
the one that was spilling the rumors about renyra
in episode 5 now he's spilling rumors about the
father of her children in this trailer the whole
line would her children but a weakness is meant
to highlight the idea that there are a bunch of
new children born to both of these women later
in the timeline so alicent has four children now
rhaenyra has probably three I think she's had her
third child now the person they show you in the
trailer is a version of amend Targaryen trying to
claim a dragon his whole thing is that he wants a
dragon for his own and he doesn't have one yet
the other Dragon Rider children all make fun of
him for not having one then there's a scene with
a teenage version of aegon II that's who this is
fighting with what seems like renira's oldest
child who's Jacaerys Velaryon remember they
were using the Velaryonname until one of their
children potentially took the Iron Throne then
they would take the Targaryen name so the whole
idea is that you have this drama between renira
and alicent's children happening in the yard like
this is just play we're just practicing but really
they're kicking the crap out of each other you
notice that Harwin strong is watching them helping
train them in the background kind of making sure
that things don't go off the rails which obviously
they do we're talking about the Game of Thrones
Universe here there is no that won't go off the
rails the voiceover line continues through them
you believe that you'll persist forever so the
whole idea is you see viserys who's now kind of
withering away almost ready to die looking down on
the yard watching them fight remember in episode
5 his whole idea is that he's got all these Grand
plans for the future of the realm the future of
the Targaryen Dynasty but it all just goes to crap
because of the dance of the Dragons that's like
the big twist in the trailer you're hearing this
voiceover you imagine that you'll persist forever
but you're waiting for the butt in that sentence
like what is the other thing when do things go
off the rails between all these different people
inside the house of Targaryen this new scene is
a much older version of Laena Targaryen who was
remember suggesting marriage with Daemon she's
been married to Daemon in that 10-year time Jump
and the two children that she has right now are
with Him Baela Targaryen and RhaenaTargaryen it
looks like in this scene she's pregnant with her
third child there's a scene of them getting ready
to hatch a dragon egg which seems like it might
be connected to jakira's getting ready to claim
his Dragon ver Max then we get the voice over
from alicent talking to aegon II tell telling
him that he will be their King pretty much all the
children that are born to these three different
families like obviously talking about Daemon as
well with Laena Targaryen all the children born
to their families are Dragon Riders so they all
do eventually get dragons Lena Targaryen starts
talking to Daemon about how they're the blood of
old valyria because she comes from House Velaryon
they're also from ancient valyrian just like
the targaryens are and they're both riding their
dragons here and we finally see Laena Targaryen
flying her Dragon vhagar and she's actually been
riding it for a long time now they even kind
of cut that out of episode five I was kind of
disappointed about that but you get an idea for
the scale here like this is a chart to show you
how much bigger vegar is than the other dragons
that's because she's a much older Dragon than the
others and they just continually get bigger and
bigger and bigger you remember way back in the
early episodes when the very very young version of
Laena kept asking viserys all about vhagar where
is vegar they keep talking about her she's too
big to fit in the dragon pit they mentioned Vhagar
again in another episode after that they just
went to set up the idea that she is eventually
the next person to claim Vhagar she's not the
last person to ride vegar the whole idea is that
dragons live for a couple hundred years naturally
unless something happens to them like somebody
comes along and kills them or another Dragon
comes along and kills them so one Dragon might
have several different Dragon Riders throughout
the dragon's lifetime for instance Balerion the
black dread had many Dragon Riders viserys was
like the last person to ride Balerion before he
died he only wrote him once right before he died
of natural causes but he was about 200 years old
when that happened the baby that rhaenyra is
holding might be a version of her third son
Joffrey Velaryon they name him Joffrey in honor of
laner's old lover Joffrey lawnmuth then when the
voiceover talks about a father being compromised
by the actions of his son they show you footage
of Lyonel Strong and Harwin strong his son and
footage of Harwin strong fighting with Criston
Cole in the yard during this fight that the kids
were having between the two of them and you hear
alicent complaining to viserys about rhaenyra's
children and it sounds like she's yelling about
rhaenyra sleeping around breaking the rules quote
quote because around court it's a bit of an open
rumor like everybody around court is whispering
spilling the tea about her having lovers so
everyone around Court believes that the father of
renira's children is really Harwin Strong and the
members of Court call them the strong boys because
all three of her children are born with the brown
hair instead of the Targaryen silver blonde color
like all of alicent's children do like this is
after her third child is born like she's holding
that baby he also has brown hair too so that's
when alicent is like enough is enough I believe
at some point during the season in later episodes
they will eventually answer that rumor but until
they officially answer it there'll just be a lot
of suggestion about who the real father of her
children are but the big idea during episode 5
is that you see harwin's strong rescue rhaenyra
earlier in the timeline the whole idea is that
he's kind of replaced Criston Cole as rhaenyra's
protector also kind of seems like replace Criston
Cole as her lover as well too you hear Jacaerys
yell dracaris and tell Vermax to breathe fire
he breathed it on this goat here it kind of
reminds you of drogon during I think it was Game
of Thrones season 4 when he killed that goat you
also see Lara strong during all these scenes so it
sounds like he isn't helping with all the rumors
about what's going on with rhaenyra's children
but that does sound like it's going to be a big
thing heading into the future of the episodes in
the whole idea that alicent really really wants to
push aegon II as the heir because of what rhaenyra
is doing like they're not really targaryens
they're not really a member of this marriage
they're secretly her bastards they shouldn't be on
the Iron Throne you can imagine all the ways that
alicent would try to use this against rhaenyra in
total alicent has four children now with viserys
aegon II the oldest Helena who doesn't feature in
this trailer anywhere but she's obviously quite a
bit older she's the only girl there's aemond
Targaryen like I said this kid here and then
alicent's other youngest child is called Darren
Targaryen he's not featured in the trailer either
I don't know if they're going to feature him in
season one but the whole idea is that her next
couple of children are born in Rapid succession so
like she has one right after the other as soon as
possible almost so like right after the events
of episode 5 she gets training again eventually
gives birth to Eamon Targaryen and then right
after that gets pregnant again gives birth to
Darren Targaryen renira's three children are also
born right after the events of episode 5 in Rapid
succession pretty much too pretty much same deal
her son jacaris is born about a year after the
events of this wedding so that they can kind of
pass him off as laner's son like oh see we got
married and then we had a child but the timing is
kind of suspect and there's the whole hair color
thing so most the people in court do not actually
believe that laner is his father then about a year
after that this other son luceras is born to her
then a couple years after luceris Joffrey is born
so like there's a couple years time gap between
luceris and Joffrey Daemon's two girls with Laena
Velaryonare also pretty close to the same age
as rhaenyra's first two children they're like
a little bit younger but pretty close the same age
like I said all them are Dragon Riders so anytime
you see one of them walking around with a dragon
egg or near a dragon egg that's part of their
Traditions but because they'll become a dragon
rider they want to put a dragon egg in their
bassinet they want the children around dragon
eggs and dragons as much as possible because
of the way they're jumping through the timeline I
don't know if we'll see all these kids eventually
Riding Dragons by the end of season one they might
wait till season two and other future time jumps
for that but like I said they all do eventually
wind up Riding Dragons that's why there are so
many dragons by season two there'll be about
17 total I think they're only supposed to be
nine during season one the little baby size
Vermax here is just like the next newest one
that they've shown you in the trailers but like
Teenage aegon the second here for instance has
already claimed a dragon his name is sunfyre but
he's not featured in the trailer alicent's second
child Helaena the girl has also claimed another
Dragon her name is dreamfyre hopefully we'll see
them in episode 6 but at least by the end of the
season we'll probably see a couple more of these
other ones but if you spotted any other Easter
eggs in the trailer footage that I didn't talk
about in the video just write it below in the
comments in my full episode 6 video will post
next week after they release it on a menu giveaway
winner the next time I post a house of the Dragon
bonus video too make sure to enable alerts from
my channel so you don't miss that everyone click
here for my Full House the Dragon episode 5 video
and click here for all my other house the dragon
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!